RONALD SMITH: Well we're going
to spend the day today talking
about clouds.
We started this last time.
So I'll do a little
bit of review.
It's all PowerPoint today, which
can be fairly boring, so
I hope you'll shout out
questions as we go through
this material.
So just remember, the subject
today-- and we started last
time-- is clouds and other
occurrences of condensed water
in the atmosphere.
So it's all about water in
the atmosphere today.
Talked about it being a water
planet, but not only in the
oceans but in the atmosphere,
as well.
Both water vapor, which is
invisible, and the clouds that
form when water vapor
condenses.
We went through these
definitions.
I won't repeat that unless
there are questions.
Are there any questions
on these definitions?
You've had a couple days
to look at those.
Question, yes?
STUDENT: I have a quick
question, whether this lecture
is uploaded on the
Classes server?
PROFESSOR: It's already there.
I loaded it this morning,
about an hour ago.
It's already there.
A PDF version of it.
Any questions on these
definitions?
These are really important.
You can't get away without
knowing these six quantities,
and these as well.
But I'll be saying more
about this as we
go through the lecture.
But these are really
important terms.
I didn't show this last, time
but I should have. It's a plot
of saturation vapor pressure
for water.
It just says vapor pressure, but
it should say saturation
vapor pressure as a function
of temperature.
Saturation vapor pressure
is defined as the--
well, there's two equivalent
definitions.
I like them both.
It's the partial pressure of
water vapor in equilibrium
with a condensed phase.
In other words, if you have a
chamber that has some liquid
water in it, and at a certain
temperature, and you wait for
a while, there'll be enough
evaporation off the surface
and the void will get filled
with water vapor.
And if you wait long enough, the
partial pressure of water
vapor in that chamber will come
to the value given by
this curve, depending on the
temperature of the system.
So the higher the temperature,
the more water vapor will
evaporate, and the higher the
water vapor partial pressure
you will have in the chamber.
Now here's a curious thing.
It actually doesn't matter
whether there's air in the
chamber above that liquid water
or not, because this is
a property of the water,
not of the air.
And I'll often mistakenly say
things like, "the air is
saturated." That's not quite
right, because it's the water
vapor we're talking about.
Now it's interesting that that
water is mixed in to air, but
the air is not really
controlling this.
This is the property
of water alone.
You'd have the same partial
pressure of water vapor above
a liquid at a certain
temperature whether there was
air there or not.
Of course, if there was air
there, the total pressure
would be higher, but the partial
pressure would be--
of water vapor would be
the same value here.
Yes?
STUDENT: What is the difference
between saturation
vapor pressure and
vapor pressure?
PROFESSOR: The vapor pressure
is what you have. Depends on
how much water vapor you have
and its temperature.
But the saturation is the value
of that quantity that
you would have when there's a
condensed phase present, and
they've reached equilibrium.
Or another way to put it is
that the saturation vapor
pressure is the maximum
you can have before
condensation begins.
In other words, at a certain
temperature, let's say 20
degrees Celsius, if I had a
vapor pressure of 1 millibar,
that is less than the saturation
curve, so nothing's
going to condense.
However, I could bring the
air to saturation--
I just said it again--
I could bring the water vapor to
saturation either by adding
water vapor to that chamber in
some way or by cooling it.
In any case I can approach
the saturation curve.
And when I get there, whether
it's there or there, doesn't
matter, the relative humidity
will be 100%.
And if I try to go beyond, using
either mechanism, the
excess water vapor will
condense out to
form liquid or ice.
So relative humidity is
less than 100% here.
When you push it to saturation,
no matter how you
do it, either by adding water
or by cooling and go beyond,
then you'll get condensed
water.
So that's the key idea there.
And I mentioned this last
time, so there.
To approach saturation,
you can add moisture.
That moves you up
on that diagram.
Or you can drop the
temperature.
And there's two common ways that
the temperature could be
dropped in an atmospheric
system.
One would be cool it
by removing heat.
Put that little piece of air
next to something cold, and so
the heat is drawn out
of it by conduction.
And that leads to something
we call radiation fog.
I'll give you examples,
advection fog, also.
Or you could cool that parcel of
air by adiabatic expansion.
That means lifting it.
You don't have to put in contact
with the cold surface.
Just lift it, and it'll expand
as it goes to lower pressure,
and cool itself by the fact
it is doing work on the
environment.
That'll drop the temperature.
And again, you'll push
toward saturation.
And if you go beyond,
a cloud will form.
So these are the three ways that
you approach saturation.
I'm going to give you lots of
examples of these today.
Stop me if you have questions.
We did this first
few last time.
Sea smoke is where you
have a warm water
surface and cold air.
You evaporate water off the warm
surface into the air, but
the air can't hold that much
water vapor, so you start to
get little liquid droplets
forming from the
excess water vapor.
The amount that you've pushed
beyond the saturation value.
And this one we talked about
last time: contrails.
You're burning hydrocarbon
fuels, byproduct of the
burning is carbon dioxide
and water vapor.
So you've added water
vapor to the air.
You've pushed it beyond
saturation.
The excess will condense out
in tiny water droplets.
Remember, the vapor itself
is invisible.
There's vapor everywhere here.
You only see the condensed
particles,
either liquid or ice.
Contrails.
We talked about this.
I think we did.
Nuclear plants have cooling
towers to get rid of heat
that's come out of the back
side of the turbines.
And what they do is
just to evaporate
large amounts of water.
Put it up in the atmosphere.
But as soon as that very humid
air reaches the colder
environmental atmosphere, it
condenses because you've added
water vapor.
It can't be held,
and the excess
goes into liquid droplets.
When you breathe out on a cold
winter day, you're doing
exactly the same thing.
Radiation fog is an example of
how we're going to cool the
air off ultimately
causing fog.
And the way you do that is
usually to have a clear night,
no clouds above, so the infrared
radiation from the
earth's surface can escape
very handily.
Maybe a good half of it escapes
to space, which cools
the surface of the earth down
several degrees overnight.
The air right in contact with
that earth's surface then is
going to lose heat by
conduction to the cold surface.
When you lose heat, you drop the
saturation vapor pressure.
You're not necessarily changing
the amount of water
vapor in the air, but you're
changing the amount that can
be held in the vapor state.
And therefore the fog forms
first for the air that's right
in contact with that
cooling surface.
That's called radiation fog.
The word radiation goes back to
how the heat has been lost
from the system.
But thermodynamically, it's
similar to cases we've already
spoken about.
This is a common thing to see,
especially in valleys, because
in slightly mountainous terrain
the air that's been
cooled by contact with the
surface will tend to run
downhill and collect
in the valleys.
So you can get radiation
fog in flat terrain.
I've seen it many times, but
I've seen it even more
frequently in slightly hilly
country where the cold air
runs down into the valley and
the fog is found most dense,
most thick, down
in that valley.
But it's still radiation fog.
Notice the clear sky above,
which is usually when you get
a good strong case of radiation
fog, it's because
there's no clouds
above overnight.
Advection fog is a
little different.
There a surface was cold to
begin with and then you
brought in moist air by the
winds over that surface.
Once you've moved the warm air
over the surface, it loses
heat by conduction again.
And the saturation vapor
pressure drops.
The relative humidity exceeds
100%, and the fog forms. So
the only difference here is how
you generated the cooling.
Instead of doing it by
radiation, you did it by
moving warm moist air over
a colder surface.
This is quite common in areas
of the world ocean where you
have a cold ocean current.
For example, the California
current that comes down along
the coast of California
is a cold current.
And when warm air masses move
over that, whether it's from
further west in the Pacific or
whether it comes off the land,
suddenly that air's going
to lose heat to
the cold water beneath.
Remember, this is
not sea smoke.
Sea smoke was the opposite.
This is cold water, warm air.
Remember, sea smoke was just
the opposite of that.
Here you're not gaining
water from the ocean.
You're losing heat to the ocean,
and causing the fog to
form in that way.
Here's another example
of advection
fog along the coastline.
It's quite common, for example,
north of here, up in
the Gulf of Maine and further
up around Nova Scotia where
the Labrador Current
comes down, the
cold Labrador Current.
It's very common.
In fact, you might have
advection fog 2/3 of the time.
You might have advection fog
over that cold flowing
Labrador Current, because
of this effect.
No matter what direction the
wind blows in from, it's
probably warmer than that
Labrador Current, so it's
going to lose heat to it, and
the fog is going to form.
So it's a very foggy area up
there where there's a cold
ocean current.
Questions here?
Maybe you've seen this.
Now we're going to talk about
clouds, which is the primary
subject of the lecture.
Clouds are formed by rising
air and the thermodynamic
mechanism is adiabatic
cooling as air rises.
As the air gets cooler, as its
temperature drops, the
saturation vapor
pressure drops.
And you will reach a humidity
of 100% and
then perhaps beyond.
If you try to go beyond, the
excess water vapor will
immediately condense out
to form a cloud.
So we're going to take a look
at a few types of clouds.
But in all cases, the
thermodynamics is the same.
So here is our friend, the fair
weather cumulus cloud
with the flat base, the
cauliflower turbulent tops,
and probably the most common
type of cloud.
I have a little time lapse movie
of-- we did a project in
my group a few months ago down
in the Caribbean, looking at
how clouds and precipitation are
generated in the tropical
belt of our planet.
We flew aircraft through
clouds and so on.
If I can get this to work, I'm
going to show you some
time-lapse photography of
cumulus clouds over the island
of Dominica.
The sun just rose.
That black to illuminated thing
was the sun rising in
the east. You're beginning to
see cumulus clouds forming
here, bubbling up, almost like
boiling in some sense.
This is heat from the land
rising, but then as the air
rises, it cools.
The humidity exceeds 100%, and
the cloud forms. But then the
air rises into the clouds and
spreads out and descends.
So maybe you can see it, but
clouds are also disappearing.
As fast as they're being
produced in the updrafts,
they're being eliminated
by the down drafts.
Because this adiabatic cooling
and heating is
a reversible process.
You cool when you lift.
You warm when you descend.
And so you're going to form
cumulus clouds and the parcels
are just moving through
these things.
Cloudy on the way up, and clear
air on the way down.
The time is in the upper box in
local time, so now it's the
evening, just before the sunset,
when the heating of
the island was reduced so
was the convection.
So this was driven by the
sun heating the island.
The warm air rising.
But then in the rising process,
the water vapor
became saturated, condensed,
and the cloud was formed.
Are there any questions
on that short--
on that short video?
When you are looking at cumulus
clouds yourself, you
normally see a fixed pattern.
You may have noticed, well it's
still here in fact, the
speedup ratio on
that time-lapse
photography was 720.
That's a big speed-up ratio.
So things are happening in this
time-lapse film 700 times
faster than they do in nature.
But that makes it wonderful,
because you can see the
process happening.
When you look at it yourself,
you see a
static cloud pattern.
If you try to watch
it, sometimes
you can see the changes.
But it's hard, because
they're slow based on
the human time scale.
You have to have a great deal
of attention focused on that
cloud to be able to watch it
evolve and change over a
period of an hour or two.
Whereas with time lapse,
we see it all before us
happening, and we can easily
understand it.
I wanted to give you a couple
other examples of what we did
in this project.
Here, for example, is a short
aircraft flight through a
couple of those cumulus
clouds.
The aircraft is equipped with
all kinds of wonderful
instruments on board.
Let me just show you what's
plotted here.
So this is a horizontal distance
in kilometers so the
airplane flew about 30
kilometers, and passed
through, depending how you
count them, two or four
different clouds.
Maybe one, two, three, four,
or something like that.
What's plotted in blue, LWC,
is the liquid water
concentration.
In those cloud drops, how much
total liquid is there in units
of grams of water, liquid water,
per cubic meter of air?
We have instruments on-board
the aircraft
that can measure this.
And so when it's zero, of course
you're not in a cloud.
A cloud is defined by its
liquid water content.
If there's no liquid water,
you're not in a cloud.
So we entered the cloud there,
we had values of one to two
grams per cubic meter
of liquid.
Then we're briefly out of the
cloud, back into another one.
Out, in.
And finally, out.
Here's the vertical motion.
The air is moving up and down.
So not much vertical motion
outside the cloud, but inside
the cloud it's noisy.
It's turbulent.
But most of the motions
are upwards.
There are few little down
bursts, but generally, most of
the air inside a cloud is moving
upwards, as I argued it
must be because it's adiabatic
cooling that is responsible
for the cloud.
Here's the water vapor
mixing ratio.
We call that the specific
humidity.
It was to units of grams
of water vapor
per kilogram of air--
how much water is mixed
into the air.
It was 11 outside the cloud, and
about 13 inside the cloud.
And then we also had instruments
that could measure
the droplet diameter of
the cloud droplets.
They're ranging between about
16 and 28 microns.
A micron is a millionth
of a meter.
These are small droplets,
so small.
These are typical
cloud droplets.
They're so small that
they don't really
fall out very much.
They just follow the air.
They're so tiny that their
gravitational acceleration is
quite small, and they mostly
just follow the air parcels.
But you can measure them as you
fly through a cloud, so
that gives you an
idea of that.
And then one more diagram from
the same experiment we did.
We found it under certain
conditions, some clouds would
have-- the cloud droplet
diameter would be larger, in
other cases, smaller.
This is the probability
density of finding a
particular cloud droplet
diameter.
On one research flight, Research
Flight 13, we found
cloud droplets that were on the
order of 20 to 25 microns.
On another day, more
like 10 to 15.
And that has a lot to do with
then whether it's going to
rain or not.
Because in order to
produce rain--
let me just remind
you of something.
A raindrop is about 100 times
larger than a cloud droplet.
100 times.
The diameter has a ratio
of about 100 times.
In order to make a raindrop, you
have to bring together a
very large number of
cloud droplets.
How many would you guess?
How many would you
have to bring
together to form one raindrop?
I thought you were
going to say.
Remember, I said the diameters
had a ratio of 100 to 1.
But it's really volumes
we're talking about.
In order to construct a
raindrop, you're going to have
to bring together the volume
of a raindrop.
So how many droplets of 100
times smaller do you have to
bring together to form the
volume of a raindrop?
STUDENT: 100 cubed.
PROFESSOR: 100 cubed.
Right.
That is to say, 10 to
the 6, or a million.
You've got to bring together
a million of these
to make one a raindrop.
Please remember that.
Because one of the longest
questions in all of
meteorology, goes back to the
days of the Greeks, is why do
most clouds not rain?
But a few do.
In some cases, there's a
mechanism that can bring
together a million cloud
droplets to form one raindrop.
But it depends to some extent on
how the cloud droplets, how
big they are to begin with.
And we found some variability
from case to case in that
cloud droplet size.
Again, the units here
are microns.
These are the small ones.
These are the cloud droplets.
The ones that just hang
up there in the sky.
Any questions here?
OK.
Now let's look at some
other cloud types.
I'm not going to go through
this exhaustively.
This is a type of cloud
that is caused--
called, in the scientific
literature it's called,
alto-cumulus.
Alto meaning mid-level cloud,
about halfway up through the
troposphere, and cumulus because
it has some turbulent
structure to it.
This particular type of
alto-cumulus, which has a kind
of banded nature to
it, is called,
colloquially, mackerel sky.
And you find that term very
often in the literature of the
sea, for example, but you find
it commonly in other types of
literature, as well.
Now you know what's
going on here.
Well, you don't know
everything.
But you know that the
air is rising
there, and sinking there.
Rising to give you the clouds.
Sinking to give you
the clear air.
You don't necessarily know
what's causing that particular
pattern of rising
and sinking air.
I think it has to do a little
bit with wind shear and maybe
a little bit with the cooling
of the tops by radiation.
But I'm not sure in this case.
But I do know that that's an
alto-cumulus cloud of the type
that is commonly referred
to as mackerel sky.
And where does the word
"mackerel" come
from, you may be asking?
Well, the fishermen that gave
that cloud its colloquial name
were catching Atlantic mackerel,
and that pattern on
the back of the fish reminded
them of that pattern.
It's not the scientific name,
but it's a common colloquial
name for that kind
of cloud pattern.
This is cirro-stratus.
So what does that mean?
Cirro means high ice cloud.
Stratus means without structure,
horizontal, a
fairly homogeneous horizontal
layer of cloud.
You see a little bit of light
and dark patterns, but
generally that is a layer of
rather continuous cloud.
It's a little bit filmy,
which reminds you that
it's probably ice.
And if it's ice, it's
certainly high.
It's certainly up in the
upper part of the--
of the troposphere.
Here is a fair weather cumulus
that is beginning to develop
vertically.
There's enough latent heat being
given off when the water
vapor is condensing.
And that heat is keeping the
cloudy air warm enough.
So it's not just stopping,
giving you a fair weather
cumulus, and then the air
descending again.
Instead, it's continued
to rise.
I don't believe it's at the
tropopause yet, so I'm going
to call that--
and it's not raining out the
bottom-- so I'm going to call
that cumulus congestious.
A growing cumulus cloud.
But now here's one that is
raining out the bottom.
You see it here.
I don't see a good anvil yet.
But because it's raining, and
nimbus means rain, I would
definitely call that
cumulo-nimbus.
It's a cumulus cloud
that's raining, and
typically these are deep.
They go from one kilometer for
the base up to 8, 10, 12
kilometers at the top.
So that's a deep cloud
spanning the entire
troposphere, from
bottom to top.
Question?
STUDENT: Can you explain again
what about the latent heat
causes it to keep on rising?
PROFESSOR: Remember we talked
about-- we defined a stable
atmosphere as an atmosphere
where a rising parcel finds
itself colder than its
environment, more dense, and
wants to fall back.
Well that might happen in this
environment, in the dry air,
but inside the cloud
that air parcel has
another source of heat.
As it rises, water vapor is
condensing, adding heat to the
air parcel, making it warmer,
and that allows it
to continue to rise.
So we would call that a moist
unstable atmosphere where, due
to that extra latent heat, the
parcel is able to rise and
form that cloud.
STUDENT: So when it condenses,
heat is given off?
PROFESSOR: Heat is given off.
Right.
Exactly.
Here's another cumulo-nimbus.
Now the bottom of it is obscured
by other clouds, so
I've taken a bit of a risk in
calling it nimbus, because I
can't see the rain coming
out the bottom.
But I can see the anvil.
That air has risen, hit the
stable stratosphere, and
spread out a little bit in the
shape of a blacksmith's anvil.
So we call it an anvil.
Usually by the time it's done
that, there is rain coming out
of the bottom.
So I'm going to take a chance
and call that one also
cumulo-nimbus.
It's probably going to have
liquid water down here
probably some ice at the top.
Sometimes underneath the anvil
you get a rather famous and
interesting cloud structure
called mammatus.
Air that's been carried up to
the tropopause, and spread out
because it can't rise any
further, then begins to
descend again in lumps.
And when the lighting is
correct, as it was here, when
the sun is low in the sky and
is illuminating these things
kind of from the side, they
take a rather dramatic
appearance of smooth descending
blobs of cloudy air
coming out of the bottom
of the anvils.
It's called mammatus.
The origin is, I
think, evident.
My favorite cloud is the
lenticular cloud.
When air is forced to rise over
a mountain range, it's
lifted temporarily, and then
sinks on the backside.
And when it's lifted it'll reach
the saturation point,
perhaps cloud will form.
But then as that air descends
back down the lee side of the
mountain, everything reverses,
and the excess water will
evaporate, and you get
back to clear sky.
So we're only seeing
half of it here.
But this is a case looking
northwest from a point that is
east of the Sierra
Nevada range.
So the air is rising here,
forming that cloud--
we don't see the other side of
it here-- the remarkable thing
is that cloud stays more or
less steady as the air
continues to flow through it.
So the cloud is fixed, but new
air parcels are entering and
leaving, entering and leaving,
entering and leaving, and the
cloud just stays there more
or less in the same place.
You may see it wiggle around a
little bit, but generally it
just stays there.
Remarkable to see.
Here's one over Mount Fuji.
Lenticular cloud.
Sometimes it's even
hard to know which
way the air is blowing.
I think the air is from
left to right here.
It's rising, a cloud is forming,
then when the air
descends, that condensed water
evaporates again, and the
parcel goes back to
just clear air.
Water vapor only, no
condensed water.
These occur in a variety of
different configurations.
I like this one.
This is called the pile
of plates lenticular.
Now why does it look
like this?
There's one mountain range.
The air is rising up over
it and then sinking.
Why that structure?
That structure can
only be there--
I thought about this for years--
there's only one
possible explanation that
I can come up with.
And that is at the water vapor
upwind of this region was
layered a little bit.
A moist layer dry layer,
moist layer, dry layer.
Moist. Dry.
Then when the whole thing was
lifted, the moist layers came
to saturation.
The dry layers, with roughly
the same amount
of lifting did not.
The moist layers
formed a cloud.
The dry layers formed the
interleaving dry air.
And then, of course, when the
air descends back down the lee
side, all the condensed
water re-evaporates.
These things are sometimes found
right, almost connected
with a mountain range as
you see them there.
But sometimes they're quite some
distance above or even
displaced from the mountain, in
which case they have been
very frequently identified
as UFOs,
unidentified flying objects.
In fact, a very large fraction
of the UFO reports over the
last 100 years can ultimately
be explained in terms of
lenticular clouds.
So be skeptical of
the UFOs enough.
The first place I would look
for an explanation of a new
sighting would be to see if it's
in a mountainous area,
see if the atmospheric
conditions were right to form
this kind of local smooth uplift
more or less stationary
because of the way this
cloud is formed.
Now that covers most of the
clouds, but I wanted to be
sure your background was a
little bit broader than this.
So I want to talk about
vortices for a minute.
Question?
Yes.
STUDENT: You said there was
the right atmospheric
condition to form those
lenticular clouds.
What is that?
PROFESSOR: Well if the air was
too dry to begin with, and you
only lifted it a few hundred
meters, you wouldn't bring it
to saturation.
It wouldn't be enough.
It's got to be humid enough, at
least in those layers, and
the mountain's got to be high
enough to lift it to
saturation.
You don't bring it to
saturation, then you won't get
the cloud forming.
Anything else on these clouds?
So, vortices.
Intense vortices, no matter how
they're formed, have low
pressure in the middle.
If you don't believe this, take
a bucket of water and
reach in with your hand and
get it swirling very fast.
You'll notice that the surface
of the water in the middle is
drawn down in the middle.
You can do it with a glass
of water, too, at lunch.
Just get it swirling, and you'll
see that in the middle,
the water's drawn down.
Hydrostatically that tells you
there's a lower pressure in
the middle of the vortex.
It has to be that way for
centrifugal force to be
balanced by a pressure gradient
force in there.
But that's not our
primary focus.
So if you accept the fact that
there's low pressure in the
middle of a vortex, if you take
an air parcel that has a
certain amount of water vapor
in it, and you move it into
the center that vortex
somehow, its
pressure will drop.
Well, what happens when you
drop the pressure of air?
It expands and cools by
adiabatic expansion.
Until this moment, I've been
talking about adiabatic
expansion as if the only way
you can do it is by lifting
air into lower pressure
regions.
But here's another way you could
do it just by taking a
parcel of air from outside and
putting it inside a vortex.
You can drop its pressure.
You could make it expand
adiabatically, drop the
temperature, drop
the saturation.
The whole story continues, is
the same, drop the saturation
vapor pressure and
a cloud can form.
So a tornado.
The main-- this part of a
tornado is called the
condensation funnel.
Now sometimes another funnel is
identified near the bottom,
and you can begin to
see evidence of it
here, the dark region.
That's called the
debris funnel.
That's material that's been
kicked up off the surface and
is being carried upwards.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about this,
actually much
more spectacular funnel.
That is just a cloud.
That's just condensed water
vapor to form cloud droplets,
because air from out here is
getting into there, and
there's low pressure
in the middle.
That's just another example of
adiabatic expansion causing a
cloud to form, in
this case, the
condensation funnel of a
tornado.
Questions on that?
We'll talk more about tornadoes
later in the course.
Pretend you didn't look
at that for a moment.
As you first looked at that
image you may say, well he
already showed us
that, didn't he?
He showed us contrails
earlier in the day.
But take a closer look at that
airplane and where the
vortices are coming from.
And they're vortices, these
little cloud lines.
They're not coming
from the engines.
Actually, they're coming from
the ends of the flaps.
That pilot, he's got his
landing gear down.
He's got his flaps down
to get extra lift.
And he's producing little
wingtip, vortices, not exactly
off the wingtip, but off
the edge of the flaps.
That's a trailing vortex.
There's low pressure inside.
And the low pressure is causing
some water vapor to
condense, to form cloud
droplets inside
that trailing vortex.
So be sure you can distinguish
that from the--
from the contrails.
Yes?
STUDENT: How does that
create low pressure?
PROFESSOR: Well, you know as a--
in order for an aircraft
to fly it has to have fast air
moving over the top of the
wing, which by Bernoulli's law
gives you low pressure, and
higher pressure at the bottom,
near the end of that wing.
Because you have high pressure
and low pressure, the high
pressure air whips surround and
forms the trailing vortex
that comes off the wing tip.
But remember, just like the
tornado the fact that there's
swirling air in that ensures
that there's going to be lower
pressure in the middle than
there is outside.
STUDENT: How common is this?
PROFESSOR: Well again, the
humidity has to be high in
order for that little bit
of pressure drop.
So I'd say a picture like this
is relatively rare, because
you probably would have to have
humidity higher than 95%
preexisting in order to get
that kind of a phenomenon.
There's another way to get the
sudden drop in pressure.
And this is off of an aircraft
flying supersonically.
It's flying very rapidly through
the atmosphere, faster
than the speed of sound.
It has its own characteristic
flow field around aircraft
when it's flying that fast,
and its own characteristic
pressure anomalies.
Normally a supersonic aircraft
where it parts the air gets
high pressure, and where the air
is coming back again near
the rear of the aircraft, you're
getting lower pressure,
even lower than ambient.
Even lower than ambient.
And we will see what
this does to the
thermodynamics of the air.
Air entering that lower pressure
region on the back of
the aircraft will adiabatically
expand and so
on, and so on.
And a cloud will form.
It's the same procedure
we've talked about.
Let's take a look at what
that looks like.
How many have seen that kind
of diagram before?
Only a few of you.
I am intrigued by this, partly
as a pilot but mostly just
as-- just for the beauty
and wonder of that.
Your first thought may be,
well, there is something
there, and the aircraft is just
flying through it, like
some kind of a membrane, or
something in the aircraft.
No.
The aircraft is flying
supersonically, perhaps 1000
miles per hour.
And this is moving along with
it, exactly following it.
Tied to it.
Notice there's another
one, little one,
just behind the cockpit.
There's a little bit of a low
pressure area there, and a
bigger low pressure area there
on the rear of the aircraft.
And the air parcels, which were
sub-saturated here, have
entered this low
pressure area.
And the story is the same.
Adiabatic expansion, cloud
formation, and then when you
get beyond, that the pressure
jumps up again.
The process reverses, and
the cloud disappears.
Question in the back.
STUDENT: What is the difference
between adiabatic
cooling and adiabatic
expansion?
PROFESSOR: Adiabatic expansion
is, they're
almost the same thing.
When you have adiabatic
expansion, you
get adiabatic cooling.
Adiabatic expansion is defined
as expanding air without
adding heat.
The word adiabatic means
without adding heat.
When you do that, when you
expand air without adding
heat, you cool it by the work
that it does on its
environment.
In other words, you drop
the temperature.
So those are almost synonymous,
but one
leads to the other.
Does that help?
Then one more example of this.
I call that the fighter plane
wearing a tutu picture.
Again, this is moving
with that aircraft.
This is not so common because
the humidity probably has to
be something like 95%, 96%,
97% in order to get that
phenomenon to occur when the
aircraft flies through it.
STUDENT: Isn't that at
higher altitudes?
PROFESSOR: Not necessarily.
It could be at any altitude,
but the relative humidity
would have to be high to begin
with, the relative humidity.
Questions on this?
Haze and pollution.
We talked about this
a little bit.
If the air is polluted and the
particles are hydroscopic,
that is, they like to attract
water, then even if the
relative humidity is less than
100%, they may attract a
little bit of water on to them
and make themselves bigger.
When they do that it's called
haze, and it reduces the
visual range.
Take a look at this photo.
Here's a nearby forest. There's
a forest on a somewhat
more distant hill.
And a forest on an even
This is up in Maine, I think,
one of my summer vacations.
Those three surfaces are pretty
much identical, and yet
that looks lighter and
bluer than this.
And this looks lighter
and bluer than that.
What's happening is if there's
haze in the air, and sunlight
is being scattered by that
haze to your eye.
So the further away the object
is-- the further away the
object is, it's not the darker
that it looks, the lighter it
looks because you're adding what
I call path radiance to
what you're seeing.
And of course as the air becomes
more and more humid,
those particles will grow
a little bit more.
That mountain may disappear.
That mountain may come to
look like that mountain.
And so this can be sometimes--
of course, you need the
particles, but the humidity
plays a role as well.
How much water condenses onto
those haze particles.
Clouds seen from space.
These are some fair weather
cumulus clouds over Central
South America, equatorial
South America
near the Ucayali River.
They're just fair weather
cumulus clouds, but they're
forming in rows.
Those are called cloud streets
in the literature.
And they are just fair weather
cumulus clouds caused by the
heating of the ground
by the sun.
But if there's a wind blowing,
cumulus clouds tend to line up
in rows, or we use
the word streets.
And so I know from this image
that the wind is blowing
either in that direction or in
that direction because clouds
line up with the wind to form
that kind of a pattern.
If I would guess, I'd suspect
it's from upper-left to
lower-right.
But I know it's always
parallel to the
wind in that case.
This is hard to see sometimes
from the ground because you
may see a cloud over there, and
a cloud over there, but
it's hard to make out this
pattern, because you're too
close to it.
Being up in a satellite, you get
to see the whole pattern.
And, of course, that's really
true for larger scale cloud
patterns like this.
Here's North America.
Here's a beautiful mid-latitudes
cyclone.
The cyclone center is here,
occluded front back to here,
warm front, cold front.
Now if you're at any location
all you see
is overcast or clear.
But from far enough away, from
up in space, you could see
this is part of a beautiful--
we call that a comma
cloud, because as
the shape of a comma.
But that's a beautiful
indication of what's called a
mid-latitude frontal cyclone.
And we'll be talking about the
structure of these later on in
the course.
Thunderstorms look like
this from space.
They have an anvil.
We've spoken about that.
That's kind of a flat part where
it's hit the tropopause
and can't go any higher
so it spreads out.
The main updraft is usually
where this bumpy part is.
The main updraft is there and
hits, spreads out, and forms a
big, big anvil.
Hurricane looks like this.
There's the eye of the hurricane
rising air, big
anvil spiraling outwards.
Clear skies from scattered
cumulus other places, but,
again, you need to be on a
satellite to see that big,
that big pattern there.
We're almost done, but I want
to remind you that we're
talking about clouds.
We're talking about
liquid and/or ice.
It's a condensed phase of water,
but it could be liquid
and/or ice.
If the temperature is higher
than zero degrees Celsius,
it's always going
to be liquid.
If the temperature is colder
than minus 40 Celsius, it's
always going to be ice.
But if it's in this intermediate
range, this
rather wide intermediate range,
of zero Celsius down to
minus 40, it could be either
liquid or ice.
If it's liquid, we call it
supercooled liquid because it
is below its normal
freezing point.
There's a definition.
It's very dangerous for ships
and aircraft, because that ice
will freeze on contact.
For example, here's a wing of an
aircraft that's been flying
through a cloud that had
supercooled water in it.
Those little cloud particles
froze on contact with the wing
and formed this rather ugly and
poorly aerodynamic shape,
making it very difficult for
that aircraft to fly.
A large number of accidents
and fatalities have arisen
from this kind of a problem.
The only thing to do is to
quickly get out of that
condition and help to melt it
off, or have some special
technology on the wing that
will throw off that ice,
either by heating or by
what's called a--
well it's a rubber thing that
can be expanded to actually
physically knock off the ice.
A boot it's called a
boot in that case.
When riming forms on the ship,
you get supercooled cloud
droplets passing over a ship
and it forms. That's very
dangerous because that'll
add mass to the
upper part of the ship.
And the moment you add too much
to that, the ship will
then spontaneously turn over,
and everyone will be lost. You
really have to get the sailors
out there chipping away at
that ice, because it has a very
dangerous weight to the
top of the ship when supercooled
water is
collecting like that.
Here's a case you can see
from time to time.
Here's a layer of probably
alto-cumulus that's liquid.
Then, for some reason, and this
is below the freezing
point, maybe it's minus
20 Celsius.
For some reason in some area
that liquid has frozen
spontaneously forming snowflakes
and they're falling
out, leaving a little clear
space in the cloud, and a
little plume of falling
snowflakes out of that region.
Look for this over the next
winter. if you look hard
enough, you'll probably find
a case or two of this.